y
[Música]
miles de ciudadanos protestaron en perú
contra el ejecutivo de manuel merino
mientras que el mandatario juramentaba a
su nuevo gabinete
las movilizaciones terminaron en fuertes
choques el ejecutivo responsabilizó a
los manifestantes mientras que los
ciudadanos denunciaron represión la oea
evita reconocer a merino como jefe de
estado
con sentidos homenajes a las víctimas
francia con memoria cinco años de los
atentados yihadistas que dejaron 130
fallecidos y centenares de heridos en
parís un lustro después el país se
encuentra en máxima alerta por una nueva
ola de atentados que mantienen el temor
entre los ciudadanos
las autoridades electorales de eeuu
aseguran que no hay evidencia de fraude
en los comicios presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre y señalaron que la jornada fue
la más segura en la historia del país
el presidente de donald trump aún no
reconoce la victoria de joe biden quien
hoy recibió felicitaciones de china por
su elección como presidente
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france24 soy valentina torre sánchez
iniciamos este informativo en perú donde
miles de ciudadanos protestaron en
rechazo al nuevo presidente manuel
merino tras la destitución de martín
vizcarra
mientras merino tomaba juramento de su
nuevo gabinete conservador el
inconformismo en las calles de
diferentes ciudades crecía en marchas
que iniciaron pacíficamente sin embargo
en la noche las manifestaciones se
transformaron en choques con las
autoridades a través de redes sociales
miles de peruanos denunciaron represión
mientras que el gobierno responsabilizó
a los ciudadanos por empezar los
desmanes andrea rincón nos cuenta lo
ocurrido antes de estos choques
las calles le viven el pulso al
presidente interino manuel merino
cientos de manifestantes se volcaron a
las calles de la capital por tercer día
consecutivo para protestar contra la
destitución del ex mandatario martín
vizcarra rechazando la decisión
legislativa que algunos calificaron de
ilegal
estamos en la calle
espontánea y pacíficamente defendiendo
la democracia peruana de un atropello
del congreso que pretende acabar voy a
previo a las manifestaciones merino ex
presidente del congreso juramento a su
gabinete ministerial liderado por el
primer ministro ántero flores-aráoz
hecho que fue duramente cuestionado por
el exmandatario martín vizcarra
respuesta se les está dando el pueblo
señor merino y más aún cuando nombra
como presidente del consejo de ministros
al señor flores aráoz es como volver al
pasado a la política tradicional
vizcarra fue destituido para el congreso
del nueve de noviembre tras ser
declarado incapaz moralmente de
continuar en el cargo el legislativo
alegó actos de corrupción que
denunciaron cuatro testigos cuando el ex
presidente era gobernador de moquegua
acusaciones que no ha aceptado ni el
presidente ni formalmente la fiscalía ni
los manifestantes pero el nuevo ministro
del trabajo peruano expresó otra cosa en
france 24 si bien es cierto nosotros
respetamos las manifestaciones populares
también es cierto que no podemos sino
decir de que están equivocados el
gobierno del presidente merino es
absoluta absolutamente legal y
constitucional y por otro lado la
situación del presente fiscal era
insostenible se habían comprobado que
había mentido en innumerables veces y
las acusaciones de haber recibido
hoy más por obras públicas eso ya
convertía su mandato en insostenible la
crisis política que merino prometió
acabar llega en medio de la crisis
económica y sanitaria auspiciada por la
pandemia y promete no irse pronto y
nuestro corresponsal en lima francisco
zacarías nos reportó más temprano cómo
terminó la jornada de la marcha de ayer
en varias ciudades en rechazo al
congreso y al presidente manuel merino
miles de peruanos marcharon en lima y en
el interior del país en rechazo a lo que
ellos consideran un golpe de estado que
ha sacado de la presidencia a martín
vizcarra en varios manifestantes que
participaron en la jornada me dijeron
que ellos van a radicalizar la protesta
y no le van a dar tregua a manuel merino
hasta forzar su renuncia se realizaron
diversos incidentes y detenciones
arbitrarias la organización de esta de
la organización de las naciones unidas
le ha pedido a las autoridades que se
protejan los derechos humanos de los
manifestantes justamente el primer
ministro ántero flores un conservador de
78 años dijo que él no entendía en la
situación de los peruanos que
protestaban ante un cambio de gobierno
y francia vive hoy una jornada de
homenajes cuando se cumplen cinco años
de los atentados que enlutaron a parís
dejando 130 fallecidos y cientos de
heridos las autoridades encabezadas por
el primer ministro jan castex y la
alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo
recorrieron los lugares donde se
registraron los ataques yihadistas y
realizaron ofrendas florales y minutos
de silencio por las víctimas
a los atentados del 13 de noviembre de
2015 dejaron atónita la capital francesa
se produjeron cuando parís todavía se
tambaleaba por los ataques de charlie
hebdo que tuvieron lugar sólo diez meses
antes los eventos fueron la peor
violencia que el país ha visto en
décadas
la primera bomba suicida explotó fuera
del estadio de francia en el norte del
país y después del pánico mientras los
aficionados subían del partido entre
francia y alemania- el entonces
presidente françois hollande que había
estado viendo el partido fue informado y
se apresuró a ponerse a salvo
solo unos minutos después unos hombres
armados abrieron fuego contra varios
bares y restaurantes en el este del país
en el mismo barrio desgarradoras escenas
se desarrollaron en la sala de música
bataclana tres atacantes mataron a 90
personas que asistían a un
multitudinario concierto de la banda de
rock eagles of death metal el asedio
terminó cuando dos de los atacantes se
inmolaron el grupo yihadista estado
islámico reivindicó la responsabilidad
de los ataques en venganza por los
ataques aéreos franceses en siria el
presidente alan lo llamó un acto de
guerra contra francia al anunciar el
estado de emergencia
los terroristas roban la vida de
inocentes
pero también quieren suspender la
nuestra
por eso digo con firmeza que francia
seguirá siendo un país de libertad de
cultura un país activo valiente dinámico
que nunca se debe al miedo la dupleta la
vida debe reanudarse por completo que
sería de nuestro país si sus cafés sus
conciertos eventos deportivos y museos
son si en los días posteriores los
dolientes se reunieron en los lugares de
los ataques haciendo una pausa para
recordar a las víctimas mientras la
investigación avanzaba a toda velocidad
el fiscal jefe de parís afirmó que tres
equipos coordinados estaban detrás de la
peor violencia en suelo francés desde la
segunda guerra mundial la policía llevó
a cabo cientos de redadas en todo el
país pero también se hicieron arrestos
en bruselas acercándose al barrio de
molenbeek en otra señal de creciente
vínculo con bélgica los investigadores
dijeron que al menos tres de los coches
de huida fueron encontrados allí se
emitió la orden para el único atacante
supervivientes al abdeslam que se dio a
la fuga y cuatro meses después en una de
las mayores persecuciones en europa
fue localizado en molenbeek en 2018 fue
condenado a 20 años de prisión por el
intento de asesinato de oficiales
policías durante su arresto se espera
que el juicio por los ataques de parís
comience en 2021
nuestra periodista en parís sérica
olavarría conversó con familiares de las
víctimas y sobrevivientes en momentos en
que la amenaza terrorista y la sensación
de inseguridad permanece casi tan alta
como hace cinco años tres olivos en una
plaza de dunn y en el norte de parís
simbolizan que la ciudad está
comprometida con la paz es una
iniciativa de michelle del plazo
habitante de la comuna que perdió su
hija elsa y a su ex esposa la chilena
patricia san martín hace cinco años en
el atentado del bataclán michelle lucha
cada día porque la paz les dan en la
batalla al oscurantismo no estamos en
una guerra de religión unir una amalgama
entre una creencia religiosa legítima
como el islam y la locura asesina de un
individuo fanatizado no puede ser
tolerada scott ahora con esta carta
participó en su comuna del homenaje
nacional a samuel para ti
el profesor decapitado por un terrorista
este tipo de noticias vuelven a abrir en
el heridas profundas
cuando ocurren cosas como la que acaba
de pasar con el atentado contra el
profesor samuel para ti el atentado de
estrasburgo o bien todo vuelve
el terrorismo aún es virulento cinco
años han pasado sí pero todas las
imágenes están ahí todos los
sentimientos fuertes están allí como yo
la paz también está en el título del
libro que hace dos años publicó ramón
gonzález un español que sobrevivió a la
tragedia del mata clan junto a su novio
una argentina y varios amigos el libro
comenzó como una terapia y terminó dando
un giro a su vida ramón dejó su trabajo
informático y hoy enseña español y está
preparando su segunda novela a todos los
niveles no sólo a nivel de escribir el
atentado significo
bueno hacer lo que lo que yo quería
hacer sin demora en un proceso
importante de terapia y además con el
libro pues ayudó mucho a sacar cosas
entonces en mi caso si se ha podido
olvidar y aunque tratan de dejarlo atrás
es inevitable para los sobrevivientes
cada atentado es una prueba al igual que
cada nuevo 13 de noviembre en el
calendario
y pasamos a eeuu las autoridades
electorales anunciaron que no hay
evidencia de alteración de los votos en
los comicios presidenciales del pasado 3
de noviembre y agregaron que las
elecciones han sido las más seguras en
la historia desde un punto de vista
técnico sin embargo el organismo indicó
que los funcionarios electorales están
revisando y volviendo a comprobar todo
el proceso antes del resultado final
cuando los estados tienen elecciones
cerradas muchos recordarán los votos
todos los estados con resultados
cerrados en la carrera presidencial de
2020 tienen registros en papel de cada
voto dándoles la habilidad de revisar y
contar cada voto si es necesario no hay
evidencia de que ningún sistema de
votación suprimiera o perdiera votos
cambiara votos o fuera comprometido de
alguna manera y conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en la ciudad de washington
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal buenos días
empecemos hablando de lo que está
ocurriendo con el partido republicano
las divisiones cada vez son más
evidentes frente al apoyo al presidente
de trump varios líderes le piden al
mandatario que reconozca la victoria de
su rival demócrata joe biden
valentina es que crece el apoyo de
republicanos al presidente electo joe
biden entre ellos está el ex presidente
george w.bush
también está el gobernador por maryland
el gobernador de massachusetts y también
el gobernador de ohio entre otros
senadores que también han manifestado ya
el apoyo y reconocen la victoria de joe
biden está también susan collins de
maine lisa murkowski de atlanta y de
alaska perdón y también está el senador
de utah
mitt romney hay que mencionar también
que el periódico las vegas review que es
propiedad de southern alderson que es
uno de los mayores donantes a la campaña
de trump pues ya saca una editorial
también en el que le pide a trump que
acepte la realidad que acepte los
resultados lo que hay que mencionar es
que esta división de los republicanos
que acepta ya la victoria de joe biden y
los que todavía la niegan se debe
sobretodo valentina porque pues hay
senadores que quieren asegurar la
mayoría en el senado una mayoría que
está todavía
juego por la elección que se va a dar de
dos senadores de dos sillas al senado en
georgia lo que dicen varios senadores es
que pues tienen que seguir apoyando a
donald trump y su retórica de fraude
para asegurar los votos de los
simpatizantes de trump en georgia al
ganar esas dos sillas y asegurar así la
mayoría en el senado
cristóbal y en medio del debate
electoral eeuu continúa registrando
cifras récord de coins de ccoo y 19 en
las últimas 24 horas se produjeron 141
142 mil 363 nuevos contagios y mil 764
muertes que ha dicho la administración
de donald trump al respecto
pues trump y su administración se ha
mantenido muy callada de valentina y de
hecho ya hay casos en el gabinete de
honor son recientes de contagio del cob
y de es el caso de 2014 un secretario de
urbanismo es el caso de mark meadows que
es su jefe de gabinete y de coro y
lewandowski que es un asesor principal
de donald trump sin embargo la
administración de donald trump firmó
hace unas horas un convenio con las
principales farmacias de eeuu y viese
world greens para facilitar la
distribución de la vacuna sobre todo de
la vacuna facer que ya pues recordábamos
ya fue pues ya está listas está
simplemente falta la aprobación del fmi
del fbi para empezar a distribuir la una
distribución que pues ya anthony fauci
dijo que se haría a finales de abril
cristóbal muchas gracias por todos estos
detalles continuaremos ampliando más
adelante y mientras continúa la negativa
del presidente de trump a reconocer el
triunfo del demócrata joe vaivén y de su
fórmula vicepresidencial kamala harris
el gobierno de china con quién trump
mantiene una prolongada guerra comercial
este viernes sus felicitaciones al
demócrata aunque aclaró que el resultado
de las elecciones se decidirá según las
leyes y procedimientos de eeuu cuando
hemos seguido la reacción de las
elecciones presidenciales tanto en eeuu
como en la comunidad internacional on
the new la igualdad y mis decisiones
respetamos la elección del pueblo
estadounidense y extendemos nuestras
felicitaciones al señor bailén y la
señora harris mientras tanto entendemos
que los resultados de la elección se
decidirá según las leyes y
procedimientos de eeuu city gracias por
su compañía continúen con más esto es
france24
[Música]